the first lesson
is to be mentally strong never to
complain
and her life was one heck of a life to
test that lesson
she was born and raised near harkov
which is a ukrainian city close to
russia
in her childhood she lived through and
survived galda muy
which is a famine in the early 30s
1932-1933
stalin had inflicted on his own people
or millions of people have died
one of the great atrocities of the 20th
century
just to give you some context the famine
that we're talking about
led to cannibalism
one historian has written that the good
people died first
the people who gave food to others
the people who refused to participate in
cannibalism
the people who gave everything they have
to their children for the survival of
their children
and therefore died before their children
did
i'll leave it at that my grandma
survived it
and as a teenager she lived through and
survived world war
ii imagine a young teenage girl
a beautiful young woman in fascist
occupied city
she rarely spoke of those times but
there were stories of
no food desperation and tragedy
and once again i'll just leave it at
that my grandmother survived
and in her eyes always remained this
glimmer of hope amidst the suffering
it's a glimmer that i've seen in the
eyes of others that i've met in my life
and it's just always inspiring to see
that triumph
that triumph over tragedy
and there's something that kind of
experience does to the human heart
it hardens it it protects it
from the outside world but also softens
it
to allow a deep connection with other
human beings
and maybe you've seen that i've done a
few things with david goggins
and i'm drawn to that kind of mindset in
him
i see my grandmother the toughest human
being
i've ever known
you